absolutely um well I'm I'm luke barats I
play Scott on the show it was a bunch of
fun we shot it quite a long time ago we
shot it about a year ago around this
time of year and stuff but uh yeah it
was a bunch of fun got to meet a bunch
of a youtuber how many people through it
stuff and I am David Harris I play Paul
in the show and yeah it was a really fun
opportunity to make a web series in a
way that was like I know it was kind of
easy to shoot and easy to create and
everybody was part of the creative
process I guess some how did you guys
originally find out about this show well
in my case um
Brigid Dale who wrote and directed the
series and also played on Mackay the
main character in it she um she and I
were both youtubers for me to add a few
years back and stuff and so we just sort
of met on a video shoot or two sort of
for for youtuber people and kind of got
to you got to know each other that way
and I actually was an empire I am an
improv teacher and I actually had her in
class many years ago and that's where we
met and so then yeah that's what Bridget
and I met and I guess she she knew that
I had a presence on Twitter and so she
got me involved as sort of another
social media guru yeah a lot of a lot of
people involved in the the series are
youtubers Twitter people if you know
very very involved in social media
themselves because that's kind of what
the show is about it's it's about these
five 20-somethings in Los Angeles sort
of making a go of it and tweeting each
other
face
each other texting each other all the
live long day and that's kind of what
the show revolves around well perfect so
I've watched a little bit of the show
and I know it's about how social media
is kind of complicates relationships
what thoughts do you guys kind of have
about that it's interesting how social
media makes everything can make
everything so public so I've noticed
that choices you may make or things you
may want to keep between somebody that
you're maybe dating or seeing in a
romantic way suddenly become so public
and available for me yeah and also I
think one of the things that Bridgette
really explained in the series is how
it's just a non-stop there there really
are no business hours for interacting
with friends anymore
you know because you got a phone on your
hip all day that you know you have no
excuse not to pick up any time of the
day
basically so how in your personal lives
how is on social media complicated your
own relationships oh boy well okay yeah
I think that it used to be that you
could have more time in between kind of
reaching out to people and now you are
expected to kind of be on call all the
time if you're in a relationship even
kind of the beginning of a relationship
I feel like you're always expected to
respond to the latest Instagram post or
like something on Facebook or something
like that for me personally it's made it
a lot more work to date it's like a lot
more maintenance of things definitely
and I mean that this interview itself is
sort of an example I don't know I'm
trying to think I I don't really want to
I don't want to go into it too much
because here we are in social media and
they just kind of get seen by it
whole world so um I I might uh kind of
take a pass you're passing the question
yeah is that legal can we pass on
questions did you guys have a moment you
know I'm gonna let you do it that's okay
this is the only one though if you have
to answer every other question after
this did you guys have like there was a
scene in the show where it was one of
those ridiculous social media moments
that at the same time you kept thinking
like oh my gosh this is so true this has
happened to me or this is like something
that definitely happens yeah I just went
camping there's a part in the in the Ark
of the of the season when most of the
cast goes camping just for a weekend and
and especially my character really
freaks out at not being able to be in
touch
digitally and yeah I just experienced
this this Easter weekend camping and
kind of making the choice to keep the
phone off and then turning it on and
getting like a world's worth of updates
all at once and kind of the anxiety of
that when you're supposed to just be
relaxing and having a good vacation yeah
actually that exact same thing happened
to me this weekend I went cam camping as
well and my phone ran out of battery
because I had the GPS on like five
minutes into it and then coming home it
was just I had like between texts and
missed calls and emails and stuff I had
like a hundred things to catch up on
late late Sunday evening they all just
caught up on me you guys seem to really
like to go camping yeah we should say it
was our honeymoon we should go ahead and
admit that I know you guys can come out
and say you were camping together and
yes not that many people in what ways
was a different filming something that
was exclusively for Hulu Plus was it
different at all has a there been
benefits to of it or disadvantages um
well I'm I'm kind of curious to see how
the the release goes because I've never
been a part of anything that comes out
on Hulu Plus before and so yeah you know
I yeah it's all been youtube for me and
you know there are just so many comments
and immediate so much immediate feedback
on on YouTube stuff whereas yeah you
know having it be on something more long
form or longer on Hulu Plus just doesn't
really have that immediate feedback so I
don't know that that's something
different for me certainly yeah and I
thought having the freedom to shoot you
know episodes of varying length and not
really having any standard so I guess to
go by with that I guess I shouldn't
speak for everyone perhaps Bridgette did
have things she needed to adhere to but
I really liked how one episode could be
ten minutes and the next one could be
five depending on you know what they're
about and what they need to cover so I
liked that freedom
why don't you guys relate to about your
characters that you were playing well my
my character's Scott he's on he's a
pretty passive dude pretty quiet and
that's that's very much how I am and
stuff so I was able to uh kind of
channel sort of sort of the nervous
energies that sort of guide my life and
just sort of enhanced those okay yeah a
lot of the circumstances of Paul's life
were similar to mine especially at the
time of shooting and in general any time
I have a role I you know try to find
something in it that makes it easy to
play as in something that that I would
bring to it that's about me that's kind
of like how I would play it's right so I
just took my own flaws like my own
neediness and dependency towards other
people especially my emotional
dependency towards people and I really
just exaggerated those to an even higher
degree than they already are built
naturally into my personality okay I
know I think my favorite scene that I've
seen is when your character is in the
van and they're just in alleyway and the
one guys yelling outside like there's a
sexual encounter 25 feet from here and
the trashcan starts moving yeah yeah
yeah I'm pretty sure that that scene was
the one that directly relates to David's
life that he was talking about that's
actually what he was talking all sex
count you're always traveling down
alleys in LA all right well what
projects are you guys working on now uh
Maya I write for a Cartoon Network show
so i'ma just write and write and write
and on pumping out YouTube videos on my
channel barats and bereta like always
just doing it yeah
I am a UCB the upright citizens brigade
brigade performer so I perform weekly
there at that theater and I also go out
on tours so starting up some spring
tours where I'll be doing some shows and
I'm writing my first romantic comedy
with a with a writing partner of mine
based on uh
on his back alley experiencing reading
underworld Craigslist sex that is that
is beautiful a family-friendly film will
be coming on next year that's wonderful
yeah is there any talk about doing a
second season first status updates um I
you probably have to ask him TV your
Bridget about that it hasn't trickled
down to us but uh you know we're kind of
the last to find out about these things
certainly written as if that could be
done there's some open-ended questions
at the end of the first season but those
diehard fans are really going to want a
second season and when I was talking to
Bridget she was talking a lot about how
this was a transmedia show and there
were a lot of ways of interacting with
the audience what are some ways that you
as cast members have been able to
interact with the audience Twitter
Facebook yeah basically all the methods
that the characters interact and in the
show served doubly for us that they are
also methods for us to talk about and
communicate about the show in real life
yeah sorry I go ahead go ahead
oh yeah kind of my last question it has
been your guys's most embarrassing
social media moment whether it was like
a Miss tweet or a photo that I got
tagged or something along those lines
yeah I think mine came uh
after Facebook sort of put their their
search bar yeah up near the top you know
like I I think I am what wanted to check
out someone's someone's page that I went
to high school from and instead put it
as my status so yeah you know I think I
wrote some girls just name as a status
this is her name I know so I learned my
lesson quickly I haven't done it since
I'm sure she was very flattered or
creeped out you know to say what story
you can go either way very quickly yeah
I say for me that you just have to be
careful when you're taking a photograph
that you're aware of the background like
what's in the background of the
photograph because even though the
subject may be fine and benign there may
be images in the background of things
that should be put away you want to see
it a little more specific or just wanna
yeah I'm talking sex toys here Carlin
get in here David let's let's talk yeah
did you hear that I'm sorry I don't know
if you did or not I definitely did I
think that's a good lesson to really
okay that will come with this video to
kids kids okay yeah just be careful
well thank you well that is not it for
all of my questions thank you guys so
much training out yeah thanks for the
thanks for hanging out and thank you
google for making this work work
Thank You Google the main reason well
awesome and I will talk to you guys
later good luck with all of your
projects okay thanks a lot thanks okay
bye